This is Jocko podcast number
one 56 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good evening, good evening
resistance.
Why didn't you resist today?
Those who have continued to live on
and comfort scold those who suffered,
yes,
resistance should have begun right there
at the moment of the arrest itself,
but it did not begin
during a daylight arrest.
There was always that brief and unique
moment when they are leading you either
inconspicuously on the basis of a
cowardly deal you have made or else quite
openly their pistols on holstered
through a crowd of hundreds of just such
doomed innocence as yourself.
You weren't gagged.
Okay?
You really can and you really
ought to cry out to cry out.
You were being arrested.
That villains in disguise are trapping.
People that are rest are being made on
the strength of false denunciations,
that millions are being
subjected to silent reprisals.
If many such outcries had been heard all
over the city and the course of a day
would not. Our fellow citizens
perhaps have begun to bristle
and would a rat in a wood arrests
perhaps no longer have been so easy.
Instead,
not one sound comes from Europe,
parched lips and that passing crowd
naively believes that you and your
executioners our friends out for a stroll.
I myself often had the chance to cry out.
Okay,
so why did I keep silent?
Why in my last minute out in the open
did I not attempt to enlighten the
hoodwinked crowd?
Why did I keep silent?
Every man always has a dozen glib
little reasons why he is right not to
sacrifice himself.
Some still have hopes of a favorable
outcome to their case and are afraid to
ruin their chances by outcry.
So they keep silent
and that right there is part
of the opening of book one
part one of the book the
Gulag Archipelago by [inaudible] and I
discussed it on the last podcast with
Jordan Peterson, but I didn't dig into
the actual text very much because,
well I had Jordan Peterson on here and I
rather just talk with him and allow him
to talk rather than read and
delve into the text itself.
But the text is really good and I wanted
to take today to go through at least,
well to go through today part one of the
Gulag archipelago and the version that
I'm going through is not the abridged
version but the full unabridged version.
So if you end up looking for some of these
passages in the abridged version that
you might not find them.
And I'm only going to go through part
one today and maybe over time we'll go
through all seven parts that
are in three different volumes.
Uh, massive volumes. By the
way, this one is 600 pages long,
um, part to volume two. It looks
like about another 600 pages.
And then volume three looks to be, I
don't know, maybe four or 500 pages.
So I think we're talking
maybe 1500 to 2000 pages,
but it's a, it's a great read and
it, like I said, in the future,
if you get these will go will, I
will, I'll say this in the future.
Yes, we will go through all the books. If
you want to get them now and read them,
then eventually you'll be able
to roll through them with us.
And it's, as I said,
I mean this, this, this book
is a very powerful book,
but I said this one when
I was talking to Jordan,
it's written and you could hear
from even the opening there. It's,
it's almost a conversation.
It's a very conversational writing
that social needs and does.
And so it's,
it's pretty easy to read because it's not,
it's just very compensates.
Sounds like somebody telling you a
story is basically what it's like.
He's asking you questions, rhetorical
questions, he's interacting with you,
the reader.
So it's a pretty fun read.
It's not fun in the fact that you're
reading about people being trapped,
tortured, murdered in a
gulag. But he does it in a,
in a lighthearted way. If that's
possible. Is that possible?
I don't know if it's possible, but
he seems to pull it off. I mean,
you can even see just, just what I just
read. Um, you know, you can see he's,
he's having a conversation
with you about it. You know,
he's having a conversation.
So that's what it's like.
Let's go back to the book and I'm gonna
pick up in a section where he's kind of
explaining, and I, and I talked about
this with Jordan and by the way, yeah,
so if you haven't listened to one 55 with
Jordan Peterson where we discuss some
of this, some of the ideas
in this book, we don't,
we don't delve into the book too much
in a magazine to cover those parts.
There's two little sections that we
covered on a cover again today and kind of
going a little bit more,
but
if you haven't listened to one 55 listen
to one 55 and then then come back and
listen to this.
This one,
this section of the book social knits
and is talking about the fact that he's a
war hero for all practical purposes and
he's about to get rolled up and arrested
by his brigade commander and he,
he's talking about his brigade commander
and the situation that he's now going
into 10 days before I had led my own
recognizance battery almost intact out of
the fire pocket in which the 12 heavy
guns of his artillery battalion battalion
had been left and now he had to renounce
me because of a piece of paper with a
seal on it.
I knew instantly I had been arrested
because of my correspondence with a school
friend and understood from what
direction to expect danger.
So He's been, if our pocket, if
you don't know what that means,
it means he was surrounded by the enemy
and he was able to lead his troops out
of there almost intact,
which means they took some casualties,
maybe lost some guys, but he was
able to lead his men out of there.
And yet he wrote a letter and he
mentioned earlier like what he says in the
letter basically says that the leadership
that Stalin's making some mistakes and
guess what?
They screen those letters.
They read what he wrote
and they arrest him.
So
war is hell.
And he talks a little bit about that here.
For three weeks the war had been going
on inside Germany and all of us knew very
well that if the girls were German,
they could be raped and then shot.
This was almost a combat distinction.
Had they been Polish girls or
our own displaced Russian girls,
they could have been chased naked around
the garden and slapped on the behind an
amusement no more.
Okay.
By the way, that's just
a little, a little, uh,
of what that war between the Russians
and the Germans was the Russians and the
Germans. We talked about
installing Greg, but yeah,
and we talked a little bit about
what happened with civilians.
There's a little taste of what happens
to civilians in those situations.
It's a nightmare
going on the history,
this is a chapter two,
the history of our sewage disposal
system and this is where he expands and
explains sort of his view of the
prisons as a whole back to the book.
And it's well known that any Oregon
withers a way if it is not used.
Therefore,
if we know that the Soviet security
Oregon or organs and they christened
themselves with this vial word praise
and exalted above all living things have
not died off even to the
extent of one single tentacle,
but instead have grown new ones
and strengthen their muscles.
It is easy to do so that they
have had constant exercise
through the sewer pipes,
the flow pulsed,
sometimes the pressure was higher than x,
then had been projected,
sometimes lower,
but the prison sewers were never empty.
The blood,
the sweat and the urine
into which we were taped,
POLST through them continuously
and he uses this, this
term, which I guess the,
the Soviets actually called the prison
system organs and how the blood of the
organs was these people.
And this is something that I talked a
little bit about with Jordan back to the
book and even though Len and at the end
of 1917 in order to establish strictly
revolutionary order,
demanded merciless suppression of attempts
at anarchy on the part of drunkards,
cool against counter-revolutionaries
and other persons.
So that's how it starts off. It starts
off with that. We're going after,
these are the people that
need to be rounded up.
The people that need to be rounded
up are drunkards, hooligans,
counter-revolutionaries in other persons.
That's where it starts.
And then it continues and it goes on.
And he writes an essay.
Leaden writes an essay
called how to organize,
how to organize the competition.
And he proclaimed this again,
this is Len pro crank proclaimed common,
the common United purpose of purging the
Russian land of all kinds of harmful in
sex and the term insects.
And under the term insects,
he included not only all class enemies,
but also workers malingering
at their work. For example,
the type setters of the Petrograd
party printing shops. So you can see,
you can see this is starting to expand
already. Mm. It starts off just, hey,
it's hooligans and drunkards
and counter-revolutionaries.
Now all of a sudden it's getting
towards workers that are being lazy.
You're being a little bit lazy. Guess
what? You need to be unity, be, uh,
arrested and you're one of these insects.
And then this is how this grows in.
And he goes through this massive list
of the people that need to be come
insects.
And he describes them as in sex.
So this included local self governing
bodies in the provinces they were in sex.
And people in the cooperative movements,
they were in sex as we're,
anyone that owned their
own home was an insect.
Okay.
There were not a few insects among the
teachers in the gymnasiums and the church
parish councils were made up
almost exclusively of insects.
All priests were insects
and all those Tolstoy.
Ian's who when they undertook to serve
the Soviet government for example on the
railroads refuse to sign the required
oath to defend the Soviet government with
gun in hand, thereby showed
themselves to be insects too.
The railroads were
particularly important for,
there were indeed many insects hidden
beneath the railroad and telegraph.
Hers they were in sex
and he just goes on and on.
Um,
all Russian executive committee of the
Union of railroad workers and other trade
unions were also often filled with
insects hostile to the working class.
So this paragraph just goes on and on and
basically what it, what it ends up as,
everyone's an insect.
That's how it ends up.
Hmm.
Everyone's an insect and therefore
everyone must be arrested eventually. Hmm.
Okay.
Here's, here's another
expansion here. The,
this is the a decree from the Council
of peoples come commit commissar ours
signed by lending on July 22nd,
1918 those guilty of selling or buying
up or keeping for sale in the way of
business food products which had been
placed under the monopoly of the republic,
they deserve imprisonment for a term of
not less than 10 years combined with the
most for severe forced labor and
confiscation of all their property.
So if you operate on any kind
of black market whatsoever,
10 years confiscation of everything you
own, that's where we're at right now.
1921 begin with the checkout order number
10 dated January 8th to intensified
the repression of the Bruges Waze.
Now when the civil war had ended,
repression was not to be
reduced but intensified.
So the civil war's over, the revolution
is over and you think, okay, the is over.
We can back off a little bit. No,
no. Now we're going to go harder.
In that same year,
the practice of arresting students began.
The arrests of members of all non
Bolshevik parties were expanded and
systematized,
not one citizen of the former Russian
state who would ever joined a party other
than the Bolshevik party could
avoid his fate. Men of religion,
we're an inevitable part of every annual
catch and their silver locks gleaned in
every sale and in every prisoner transport
en route to the soviets t islands.
And those are prisons.
Monks and nuns who's black habits had
been a distinctive feature of old Russian
life.
We're intensively rounded up on every
hand placed under arrest and sent into
exile.
As Tanya Covich wrote,
you can pray,
you can pray freely,
but just so god alone can here.
So you're allowed to pray.
But only God can hear it.
Meaning don't let anyone else here.
And by the way,
because she wrote that she got
a 10 year sentence for that,
all persons convicted of religious
activity received tenors,
which is the 10 year sentence.
So you can see how this just
gets completely out of control.
And one thing about this book is it's,
it's not really chronological.
So it goes through hole
like this first chapters.
It goes through from like the revolution
all the way through after the war so
and then you and then you go through,
it's not chronological,
it just kind of jumps around
a little bit so you have to,
you kind of have to just pay attention
the whole time to what time frame he's
talking about. Luckily it gives a lot
of dates on when things are happening.
For instance here back to the book,
this therapy continued full speed from
1927 on and immediately exposed to the
proletariat all the causes of our
economic failures and Sorta just, okay,
let's pay attention to this.
All the causes of our economic
failures and it's shortages,
so obviously Russia is going through
all kinds of problems at this time and
here's what caused them.
There was wrecking and wrecking is
their term for basically a saboteur.
Someone that's causing
the problems is a record.
There was wrecking in the people's
Commissariat of railways roads.
That was why it was hard to get
aboard the train and why there were
interruptions and supplies.
There were,
there was wrecking in the Moscow electric
power system and interruptions in
power. There was wrecking in the oil
industry, hence the shortage of kerosene.
Kerosene.
There was wreckage and textile,
hence nothing for a working
man to wear where the,
in the coal industry there
was colossal wrecking,
hence no heat in the metal,
a jury in a metal, a jury,
defense machinery,
shipbuilding chemical mining,
gold and platinum
industries in irrigation.
Everywhere there were these pos filled
boils of wrecking enemies with slide
rules were on all sides.
So there they have problems in the
country and it's the what the party is
saying, hey this is because
we've got these, these wreckers,
the saboteurs everywhere,
enemies with slide rules,
the GPU puffed and panted in its
efforts to grab off and drag off all the
wreckers in the capitals and
in the providence provinces,
the Gpu collegiums and the
proletarian courts kept hard at work,
sifting through the viscous sewage and
every day the workers gasp to learn and
sometimes they didn't learn from
the papers of new vial deeds.
So he had the, the, the, the state press,
putting out all this is what's happening.
These are the wreckers.
Every industry,
every factory and every handicraft artele
had to find wreckers in its ranks and
no sooner had they begun to
look than they found them,
continues on when not long afterward,
the new peoples commissar of the railroads
ordered that average loads should be
increased and even
doubled and then tripled.
And for this discovery received order
of Lennon along with other others of our
leaders,
the malicious engineers who protested
became known as known as limiters.
They raised the outcry that this was too
much and would result in the breakdowns
of the rolling stock and they were
rightly shocked for their lack of faith in
the possibilities of socialist transport.
So that right there sums up a lot because
you're in this situation and there's
some buddy at the top that saying,
oh,
we need to transport more stuff on the
railroads. Cool. Just load them up more.
And he actual engineers are saying
they can't handle that much weight.
Hey, they can't handle that much
weight. It's going to ruin the trains.
It's going to break the trains.
And what do they do? Shoot him,
shoot him in the back, shoot him
in the back of the head because,
and they called him limiters. They
gave him a name. You're a limiter.
You just don't want to make this happen.
That's your problem.
And there's a,
there's a
great passage that I read in a book that
I'm going to read right now and this
book that I'm gonna pull up real
quick passage from a book called basic
economics written by
a famous very famous
economist I should say,
named Thomas Soule.
And he's just talking about,
he's talking about how they tried to
regulate prices in the Soviet Union.
And there was a way to set the
prices on everything. And he's,
and it says this, so this is
from, this is the role of prices,
is the name of the chapter and basic
economics by Thomas Sal. The significant,
the significance of free market prices
and the allocation of resources can be
seen more clearly by looking at
situations where prices are not allowed to
perform this function during the era of
the government directed economy of the
Soviet Union. For example, prices.
We're not set by supply and demand,
but by central planners who sent
resources to their various uses by direct
commands,
supplemented by prices that the planners
raised or lowered as they saw fit.
And now he goes into this part where he
takes these two Soviet economists and
they described a situation in which
their government raise the price.
It would pay for mole skins,
leading hunters to sell more of them.
And here's that description and this is
these two Soviet economists smell Evan
pop off who described the situation
where the government raised the price,
it pay for mole skins.
Here we go,
state purchases increased and now all
the distribution centers are filled with
these pelts.
Industry is unable to use them all and
they often rot in warehouses before they
can be processed. The Ministry of
Light Industry has already requested.
Go, Scott, come in.
The Ministry of Light Industry has already
requested twice to lower purchasing
prices,
but the question has not been decided yet.
And this is not surprising,
it's members are too busy to decide.
They have no time besides setting
the prices on these pelts.
They have to keep track of
another 24 million prices.
So that's what happens. And that's what's
going on. You've got somebody trying to,
essentially it's the opposite
of decentralized command.
Mm hmm. So you've got,
you've got people trying
to figure out what a,
to what this mole skin pelt should cost.
And what happens is when they,
when the government raises the price,
they'll pay for it.
What do all the people do?
They go and gather more of these pelts
and now there's an overstock of them.
And they try and get them to lower the
prices. So people weren't stopping.
We'll stop,
turn them in,
but they can't do it quick enough because
I've got 24 million other prices that
they got a set for the government.
So that in a nutshell is why all these
problems are one of the major reasons why
all these problems are occurring.
And whenever somebody tries to, um,
resist what commands are being given,
they're getting shot. Limiters.
Yeah. And this is one I talked about
a little bit with Jordan in September,
1930 the famine organizers were
tried with a great hue and cry.
They were the ones,
there they are.
Okay.
There were 48 records in the food industry
stolen,
carried out the first such effort in
connection with the trial of the famine
organizers.
And how could it not succeed when
everyone was starving in boldness Russia?
And everyone was always
looking about and asking,
where did all our dear Brett get to?
Therefore,
before the cur court verdict,
the workers and employees raffles,
he voted for the death penalty
for the scoundrels on trial.
It was the newspaper March of millions
and the roar rose outside the windows of
the courtroom. Death, death, death.
So for these types of reasons for
this centralized command doesn't work.
Not to mention we,
you know what they did,
took the farms away from the people
that actually knew how to farm there.
There's complete famine and they're blue.
They're blaming it on the 48 people
that were saboteurs inside the,
uh,
the agriculture industry.
Completely insane.
And this one I read with Jordan on a,
read it again in the Russian, in Russian,
a Kulak is a myth,
a miserly,
dishonest rural trader who
grows rich not by his own labor,
but through someone else's,
through your surgery and operating as
a middleman in every locality be even
before the revolution.
Such cool acts could be numbered on
one's fingers and the revolution totally
destroyed their basis of activity.
Subsequently,
after 1917 by a transfer of meaning,
the name Kulak began to be applied to
all those who in any way hired workers,
even if it was only when
they were temporarily short
of working hands in their
own families.
So a Kulak started off as someone
that was trying to rip people off,
but then they just started
applying it to everyone.
Anyone that hired someone was a Kulak
and it has a derogatory tone to it.
Okay,
continuing on,
but the inflation of this scathing term
Kulak proceeded relentlessly and by 1930
all strong peasants in general,
we're being, we're being so cold,
all peasant strong and management,
strong and work or even
strong merely in convictions.
The term Kulak was used to smash
the strength of the peasantry.
Beyond this.
In every village,
there were people who in
one way or another had
personally gotten in the way of
the local activists.
This was the perfect time to settle
accounts with them of jealousy, envy,
an insult,
a new word was needed for all those
victims as a class and it was born by this
time. It had no social or
economic content whatsoever,
but had a marvelous sound pot,
Kulak neck,
a person aiding the cool acts. In
other words, I consider you a comp,
an accomplice of the enemy.
Now,
what's interesting about this, and I had,
I had a bunch of people point this out,
this, this is when we take
words, powerful words,
and we start to throw them at people
and we use them universally, that's,
that's going to cause a problem.
And you can see it all the time
right now in social media and in the,
yeah,
I guess you see it primarily in social
media from like far left extremists and
far right extremists to the far right.
Anybody that's to the left to them
is like a communist to the far left.
Anybody that's to the right of them
is a racist or a Nazi and they,
those words around and those words
that you shouldn't use those words.
It's like using Kulak like that.
That's not the person that hires someone
isn't a Kulak. Yeah, right. Yeah.
I like that doesn't work.
So we escalate these terms and that's,
that's not a healthy thing to
do. I mean, I think it was, um,
when, yeah, I mean,
when Jordan Peterson gets
compared to Adolf Hitler. Yeah,
right. They come here, Jordan
Peterson to Adolf Hitler.
Okay.
Come on. Yeah. Okay. You don't like
some of Jordan Peterson's ideas. Yeah.
Okay. That's cool. Don't
call them Adolf Hitler. Yeah.
Like that's just not realistic.
Yeah.
It's not helpful to, you know, or
people don't like his ideas or whatever,
like for a specific reason,
you know,
rather than identify
the reason they dislike,
package them up and put an ugly
bow tie on it and be like, yeah,
I hate you.
You kind of thing
in the right. You know, if you
think about during McCarthyism,
right, it was, hey, anti America, you're
anti American, you're a communist.
It was like they were
flagging people like that.
So both sides can do this. In
this case, it's, in this case,
it's the [inaudible]. It's the
communists be escalating these terms.
We've seen the right do it. We see the
left do it. Not a smart thing to do.
Don't throw those terms out
where they don't belong. Yeah.
Talk to him about this a little bit with
Jordan and there was a wave and then we
talked about wave.
You talking about waves of people that
would flow into the prisons and there's
all these different ways.
You're talking about dozens
and dozens of different waves.
There was a wave for snipping ears,
the nighttime snipping of individual
ears of grain in the field,
a totally new type of agriculture
activity, a new type of harvesting.
The wave of those caught
doing this was not small.
It included many tens of thousands of
peasants. Many of them, not even adults,
but boys,
girls and small children whose elders had
sent them out at night to snip because
they had no hope of receiving anything
from the collective farm for their
daytime Labor,
Labor for this bitter and not
very productive occupation
and extreme of poverty
to which the peasants had not been driven.
Even in serfdom,
the court's handed out a full measure,
10 years for what ranked as an especially
dangerous theft of socialists property.
Again, that again, that's why I say
this book is kind of light to read,
write and he's, he's,
he's kind of funny, right?
Especially dangerous staffed
of Socialists properties.
Talking about taking a
one year of of grain.
Is he saying that like on his own
kind of thing or is, is that what,
what the people say? That's
you. That's what the,
like you stole communist
Socialist property,
you stole it and you must be destroyed
10 years cause you took a little piece of
grain. Yes. Like these, like if you get a,
I dunno Jay walking ticket or something,
hey you committed a crime here, criminal,
you know, kind of thing. Yeah.
You can just call someone a
criminal usually has them,
even though technically you know,
they're not kinda wrong, you know?
Yeah. I got rolled up in Vegas.
I was with sarge.
Sure.
We were crossing one of the big streets
in Vegas and I had to grab something or
I dropped something or I was tying
my shoe or doing something and the,
the walking light went red.
But the cars weren't going yet and
sarge had already walked across.
So I just kind of jogged cross,
you know,
before any car started
moving squad car lights.
Then 10 seconds later,
four squad cars.
I don't know if they thought I was
somebody else. So I'm there, you know, on,
on the curb. Facedown. Facedown.
Sarge is videoing it.
Laughing at me.
Yes I was a criminal and still eat.
But what then did what they do?
You did you get dressed, you
know, they gave me a ticket.
They gave me a ticket for jaywalking.
Yeah, well I guess criminal rate.
What's a criminal? And they probably
thought, they probably thought, oh,
we're going to roll up this
drunk idiot guy. I'm totally,
so it was up there for the UFC, you
know, I was up there with a fighter.
I don't know, we were probably
going to, uh, you know,
cut weight or something with a fighter
and there I am getting rolled up,
rolled down the road.
There's no cars, cars.
They must've thought I was somebody else
who has to be thought a big, you know,
and it's like, Hey, this guy looks like
he could get in trouble or something.
And Jay walking, obviously a car, but the,
I guess when you think about a criminal,
right? Criminal, what's, what's,
what does that, is that like someone
who commits? Imagine it. In this case,
what they'd say is,
Oh,
you were blocking the transportation
of socialist property, therefore you,
that's a crime against the state you
get in 10 years. That's the same.
That's exactly what we're talking about,
has exactly what we're talking about.
Western jaywalking get 10 years for going
out and clipping a single grain of a
single year of corn or grain,
getting 10 years for that and you're 12
years old or whatever crime against the
state. It's like when people throw
around the word treason, you know?
You know how like when when people
get into political debates around oil,
that's treason. That's
the, that's your right.
There's people throw that word around
when it shouldn't be thrown around.
Be careful when you, when
you commit treason, that's
definitely a big deal, man.
So people say, uh Oh, what?
What's a good example of fats?
Treason.
Treason is a big deal.
You shouldn't throw that word around
unless you're thinking somebody needs the
death penalty. Yeah. So yeah,
it's a good example.
Check back to the book.
Paradoxically enough,
every act of the all penetrating eternally
wakeful organs over a span of many
years was based solely on one article of
the hundred and 40 articles of the Non
General Division of the Criminal Criminal
Code of 1926 so this is where all this
crap came from.
They wrote this criminal code of
1926 and the including the great,
powerful,
abundant,
highly ramified multi-form wide sweeping
article 58 which summed up the world
not so much through the exact terms
of its sections as in their extended
dialectical interpretation.
In all truth,
there is no step fought action or
lack of action under the heavens,
which could not be punished by the heavy
hand of article 58 the article itself
could not be worded in such broad terms,
but it proved possible to
interpret it this broadly.
Article 58 was not in that division
of the code dealing with the political
crimes and nowhere was it
categorized as political? No,
it was included with crimes against public
order and organized gangsterism in a
division of crimes against the state.
And then he goes through all these various
sections of article 58 which had 14
sections
in section one we learned that any action,
and according to article
six of the Criminal Code,
any absence of action directed toward
the weakening of state power was
considered to be counterrevolutionary
broadly interpreted.
This turned out to include the refusal
of a prisoner in camp to work when the
state went in a state of
starvation and exhaustion.
That was a weakening of state power
and it was punished by execution
because if you're in
prison and you're starving,
but you're not doing the
work you're supposed to do,
you're doing something that's hurting
the state. So he needed to die.
This is a key. You can't, I was having
trouble and I think even Jordan,
like we were trying to get the explained
that this is like a sick comedy,
like you can't really, we kept saying
back and forth to each other. We're like,
you can't make this up.
You can't make this up.
Like, you can't make that
up. And this is real. Yeah.
This a sick comedy. That's an interesting
yet I'm kinda accurate way it is. He,
you know, it's like, you know
how I can't think of an example.
You know how someone will, like,
he'll say, I dunno cable actually,
you know what it was? It was like
some cable commercial, is it,
they do this in a funny way of
comedy way. They'll say, hey,
don't get cable because if, and then
it'll say like, what does he say?
He says something like, yeah, if
you don't listen to your parents,
you don't do your homework.
If you don't do your homework,
you don't get a good job if you
don't get a good job, you know?
And it's this whole thing.
And then crack house. Yeah.
So don't end up in a crack
house, you know, kind of thing.
And the related to the city and it's
like, I see what you did there, you know,
and each one. Right. But it's
like you just being funny,
like obviously that's not that,
you know,
but they're just drawing all these
parallels, tear everything. So this one,
they must be the same, you know, kind of
thing, you know, like, yeah, if you get,
if you cancel cable,
I forget how it goes.
But you know, to your
point, this is that kind of,
this sounds like it just be that
crazy. Exactly. But this is real.
When our soldiers were sentenced to only
10 years for allowing themselves to be
taken prisoner action injurious to
the cell, Soviet military might,
this was humanitarian to
the point of being illegal.
According to the stolen this code,
they all should have been shot upon
their return home. So they're saying,
you know what,
the people that were allowed,
the Soviet soldiers that allowed
themselves to be captured,
they only got 10 years,
which is actually kind of illegal
because they should have been shot
via article 19 of the criminal
code via intent. In other words,
no trees and had taken place.
But the interrogator envisioned an
intention to betray and that was enough to
justify a full term.
The same as actual.
So if I just think you had the intent,
that's good enough.
You're getting 10 years.
Section three was assisting in any way
or by any means a foreign state at war.
This section made it possible to condemn
any citizen who had been an occupied
territory,
whether he had nailed on the appeal of
a German soldier shoe or sold them a
bunch of radishes.
You get your Tanner right there.
There's these two things,
psh,
which is suspicion of
espionage and an Nsh,
which is on proven Aspen espionage.
You can charge someone
with unproven espionage.
What does that even mean? Hey,
we're just, you know, we're,
you're guilty for unproven. It's like
you're guilty of unproven murder.
What does that mean? Oh, it's not proven,
but that's what you're guilty of
and that's why you're going to die.
Or maybe it's the kind of like, you know,
here they'll say like, hey, he, he's a,
he's in a legend. You know, before you
are proven in the court of law kind,
maybe you're in that window, you know, no,
nothing proven espionage and you're
going to go to prison for 10 years
years for it.
Section eight covered terror.
Terror was construed
in a very broad sense,
not simply a matter of putting
bombs under governors carriage is,
but for example,
smashing the face of a personal enemy.
If he was an activist in the party
or the police that was terror.
And then he starts talking about section
10 which is propaganda or agitation
containing an appeal for the overflow,
subverting or weakening
of the Soviet power.
Andy equally the dissemination or
preparation or possession of literary
materials of similar content. So
any, if you're drawn in propaganda,
you can get trouble.
But here we go.
The term preparation of literary materials
covered every letter note or private
diary, even when only the
original document existed.
So Amy thing that you
write down is subject.
Yeah,
well that's why he went to
prison for a letter. Right.
The real wall underlying this,
the arrest all those years
was the assignment of quotas.
The norm set the planned allocations.
Every city, every district,
every military unit was
assigned a specific quota of
arrest to be carried out by
a stipulated time.
That's like when cops get the quota
for the speeding tickets. Yeah.
That's when you get the ticket for
for [inaudible] 38 in a 35.
Is that true though? Sometimes it
is. Again, I don't know. I thought,
I mean I thought it was true, but I
have no idea. Like is that just a myth?
You know how like people they, they're
just mad because they got a ticket,
you know, I call it photo but
it's not even real. You know,
like that's not even a real thing. I
have no idea. It could be a method.
I just believed. Yeah. You know,
cause you've probably got that
ticket when you're 38 in the 35.
Him and me neither.
That's why I'm questioning it.
I did get pulled over a few months
ago. But eyebrow. Your tinted windows.
No, I was going too fast in this
area. Oh, straight up. Speeding. Yeah.
Well you got off. They give
you a break. Yeah. Cause they,
they'd recognize, you know
what I think,
uh,
check
back to the book piles of
Victims Hills a victims.
Here's some other people got arrested
and electrician had a high tension line
break in his sector. 58, seven.
That's the article 20 years,
okay.
A plumber turned off the
loud speaker in his room.
Every time the endless letters
to Stalin were being read,
his next door neighbor denounced him.
Where aware is that neighbor today he
got soe socially dangerous element.
Eight years.
Okay.
By the end of numbered, by the end of
summer 1941 becoming bigger in the autumn,
the wave of the encircled was surging.
It again,
the waves talking about waves of prisoners
that are showing up and the waves of
the encircled were surging in. These
were the defenders of their native land,
the very same warriors whom the cities
or had seen sent off to the front with
bouquets and bands a few months before
who had then sustain the heaviest tank
assaults of the Germans and in the general
chaos and through no fault of their
own had spent a certain time as isolated
units, not in enemy imprisonment,
not at all,
but in temporary INCIRCL mint
and later had broken out.
You understand what that means?
It means they're surrounded by the
enemy didn't get captured by the enemy.
They get surrounded for a little
while and then they break out.
They'd get back to friendly lines and
instead of back to the book and instead of
being given a brotherly embrace on their
return such as every other army in the
world would have given them,
instead of being given a chance to rest
up to visit their families and then
return to their units. They were
held on suspicion, disarmed,
deprived of rights,
and taken away in groups to identification
points in screening centers were
officers of the special branches
started interrogating them,
distrusting not only their every word,
but their very identity
traders of the motherland under 58 one B,
but at first until the standard
penalty was finally determined,
they got less than 10 years.
Yeah.
You can't imagine that
people would go along.
You can't imagine that people
go along with this, right? Yeah.
The level of fear that
you have to have as a,
as a nation and as a people
to go along with that,
right there are our frontline
troops were surrounded by the enemy.
They managed to escape and get back in.
Now we're going to put them on
trial and put them in prison.
It's, it's, it's insanity.
Next chapter talks about interrogation
going to the book.
If the intellectuals in the plays of
checkoff who spent all their time guessing
what would happen in 2030 or 40
years had been told that in 40 years
interrogation by torture
would be practiced in Russia,
that prisoners would have their
skulls squeezed with iron rings,
that a human being would be
lowered into an acid bath,
that they would be trust up naked to be
bitten by ants and bedbugs that are ram
rod heated over a primus stove
would be thrust up their anal canal.
The secret brand that a mans genitals
would be slowly crushed beneath the toll
the boot, and that in the
luckiest possible circumstances,
prisoners would be tortured by being kept
from sleeping for a week by thirst and
by being beaten to a bloody pulp.
Not one of checkoffs plays would have
gotten to its end because all the heroes
would have gone off to insane asylums
if the intellectuals and the plays of
checkoff who spent all their time guessing
what would happen in 2030 or 40 years
had been told that in 40
years interrogation by
torture would be practiced in
Russia.
That prisoners would have their
skulls squeezed within iron rings,
that a human being would be
lowered into an acid bath,
that they would be trust up naked to be
bitten by ants and bedbugs that are ram
rod heated over a primus stove
would be thrust up their anal canal,
that a mans genitals would be
slowly crushed the Tova Jack boot,
and that in the luckiest
possible circumstances,
prisoners would be tortured by being kept
from sleeping for a week by thirst and
by being beaten into a bloody pulp.
Not one of checkoffs plays would have
gotten to its end because all the heroes
would have gone off to insane asylums.
Horrible.
So they have these,
they're doing these savage
interrogations and torture.
Continuing on the time allotted for
investigation was not used to unravel the
crime in 95 cases,
out of 102 exhaust where down weaken and
render helpless the defendant so that
he would want to end it at any cost.
Then he talks about some of
the methods that we're using.
He talked about some of the torture and
these were just some of the kind of the,
the basic, the, the, the base line
abuse that you're going to get.
You're going to get capped
from sleep. You're going to
get persuasion. They'd say,
look, you're going to get prison term no
matter what happens, but if you resist,
you croak right here in prison, you
lose your health. But if you go to camp,
you'll have fresh air and sunlight.
So why not sign this paper right now?
Okay?
They do that. They do, they
do psychological contrast,
you know, good cop, bad cop, humiliation,
extreme confusion, intimidation.
They tell him we've got hard labor camps.
Now if you can fast,
you go to an easy camp.
But if you're starting or stubborn,
you'll get 25 years in handcuffs.
In the minds,
they'd lie. Of course they'd
play on the affections for those.
One loved
will arrest your daughter in locker
in this cell with syphilis sticks.
That's that one that they always throw,
right? They're going to break. Oh,
they can't break you. Cool. Guess what
they're going to do to your daughter.
Guess what they're gonna do to your wife.
Guess what they're
going to do to your son.
Hmm.
Now
he has a great paragraph and I talked
about this a little bit with Jordan,
but it's a reflecting on his behavior.
And this is when he started
talking to him. And again, I
okay,
skip through a lot of the interrogation.
Um, you have to read the book.
You have to read the whole book,
and he to really jump into that,
I hit the high wave tops of it.
And this section, he's talking about the
guards, right? The people that they call,
he called them blue caps.
These are people that were the guards,
people that were processing
you through the gulags and
you know,
much like,
much like Jordan kinda talks about
seeing himself as the bad guy,
right? The perpetrator as opposed
to always seeing like, oh,
everyone thinks I wouldn't do that.
I'd be one of these victims. He,
uh,
social knits and sees himself in a
way he reflects on the way he behaved
actually as an officer,
as a privileged officer
in the Russian army.
And this is,
this is such a great little section about
leadership because it tells you what
not to do as a leader.
So here we go.
And this is a great start off to this.
It starts off here. Back to the book.
Pride grows in the human heart,
like lard on a pig.
I tossed out orders to my subordinates
that I would not allow them to question,
convinced that no orders could be wiser.
That's check number one right there.
There's,
these are things not to do as a leader.
I throw out orders to my subordinates
without letting them question them,
convinced in his own mind that da my
orders the best, worst, completely wrong.
Next,
even at the front where one might have
thought death made equals of assault.
My power soon convinced me that
I was a superior human being
wrong.
You're not better than your troops.
Next seated there, I heard them
out as they stood at attention.
I interrupted them.
I issued commands.
I addressed fathers and grandfathers
with the familiar downgrading form of
address.
While they of course address me formally,
I sent them out to repair wire under
shell fire so that my superiors would not
reproach me.
I ate my officer's ration of butter with
roles without giving a thought as to
why I had a right to do it and why the
rank and file soldiers did not. So,
hey,
we're out there in the field.
You're going to eat whatever shoe leather
and I'm over here eating my butter
would roles.
I,
of course had a personal servant
assigned to me in polite terms,
an orderly whom I badgered one way or
another in order to look after my person
and prepare my meals
separately from the soldiers.
I forced my soldiers to put their backs
into it and dig me a special dugout at
every new BIVOUAC and to haul the heaviest
beams to support it so that I would
be as comfortable and as safe as possible.
And wait a minute,
yes,
my battery always had a guard house
to meaning a little prison cell.
What kind of guard guardhouse
could there be in the woods?
It was a pit of course,
although it had a roof
on,
it
talks about imprisoning song.
Uh,
if he should cough was imprisoned there
for losing his horse and pop golf for
maltreating his car beand yes,
just a moment. I can remember more.
They sewed me a map case out of a German
hide, not human, but from a car seat,
but I didn't have a strap for
it and I was unhappy about that.
Then all of a sudden they saw some
partisan commissar from the local district
Party committee wearing just the right
kind of strap and they took it away from
him. We are the army. We have seniority.
Yeah.
Finally I coveted that scarlet box and
I remember how they took it away and got
it.
For me,
that's what shoulder
boards do to a human being.
So when you get rank,
when you put on those shoulder boards,
keep your ego in check.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't act like that.
Okay
then believe me,
I mean I saw plenty of people like act
like that in the military and they were
hated by their troops.
Okay.
Continuing on.
So let the reader who expects this book
to be a political [inaudible] slam,
it's covers shut right now.
If it were only all so simple,
if only there were evil people somewhere
insidiously committing evil deeds and
it were necessary only to separate them
from the rest of us and destroy them.
Yeah.
But the line dividing good and evil cuts
through the heart of every human being
and who is willing to destroy
a piece of his own heart.
So if you're not careful,
you got that evil in you.
Okay.
During the life of any heart,
this line keeps changing place.
Sometimes it's squeezed one way by
exuberant evil and sometimes it shifts to
allow enough space for good to flourish.
One and the same human being is at various
ages and under various circumstances,
a totally different human being.
At times he's close to being
a devil at times to sainthood,
but his name doesn't change.
And to that name we ascribe
the whole lot good and evil.
And that's a line that you hear Jordan
Peterson read that line a lot or say that
line a lot.
The line dividing good and evil cuts
through the heart of every human being
cause we all got a little
piece of darkness in our
hearts that you need to watch
out for.
Hmm.
Continuing on a little bit on that theme,
the trouble lies in the way these
classic you evil doers are pictured.
They recognize themselves as evil doers,
doers,
and they know their souls are black.
And the reason I cannot leave unless
I do so I'll set my father against my
brother. I'll drink the victim
sufferings until I'm drunk with them.
But no,
that's not the way it is to do evil.
A human being must first of all,
believe that what he is doing is good or
else that it's a well considered active
in conformity with natural law,
fortunately is in the nature of
the human being to speak, uh,
to seek a justification for his actions,
ideology,
ideology.
That is what gives evil doing.
It's long sought justification and
gives the evil doer the necessary
steadfastness and determination that is
the social theory which helps to make
his axing good instead of bad in his own
eyes and other's eyes so that he won't
hear reproaches and kerchiefs curses.
But we'll receive praise and honors.
That was how agents of the inquisition
fortified their wills by invoking
Christianity,
the conquerors of foreign
lands by extolling the grand
jury of the motherland,
the colonizers by civilization,
the Nazis by race,
the Jacobeans early and late by equality
brotherhood and the happiness of future
generations.
Thanks to ideology.
The 20th century was faded to experience
evil doing on a scale calculated in the
millions. This cannot be denied
or passed over nor suppressed.
How then do we dare insists
that evil doers do not exist?
And who was it that destroyed
these millions? Without evil doers,
it would have been no archipelago.
So this is again,
something that we see a lot today when
people get on and we see it in the past.
Obviously he gave all the examples
right there. I mean the inquisition,
we haven't covered that on the
podcast yet, but we probably need to.
Hmm.
Because that was a damn nightmare.
Yeah.
And it was a nightmare with
people that were saying, hey,
this is for the good of Christianity.
Yeah.
And you can go right on down the list
when people make, do people do evil,
they have this ideological oftentimes
have this ideological backing behind them.
They're doing it for this great cause.
And he gets here and I got a book in the,
um,
in the queue that's
probably going to get done,
which we're going to approach
this thing right here.
Evidently evil doing also
has a thresh hold magnitude.
Yes.
A human being hesitates and Bob's back
and forth between good and evil all his
life. He slips, falls back, clambers up,
repents. Things begin to dark and again,
just so long as the threshold
of evil doing is not crossed,
the possibility of returning remains
and he himself was still within reach of
our hope.
But when through the density of evil,
the result either of their own extreme
degree of absoluteness of his power,
he suddenly crosses that threshold.
He has left humanity behind and without
perhaps the possibility of return.
So there's some situations where people
just go, they're not coming back.
They're just going to do evil.
That's the way it's going to be.
And I have a book in the queue right now
that we're probably going to do that.
We'll explore that departure
from being able to return.
Okay?
Continuing on.
The only soldier in the world who cannot
surrender is the soldier of the world's
one and only Red Army.
That's what it says in our military
statutes. You cannot surrender,
no surrender. There is war,
there is death, but there is
no surrender of discovery.
What it means is go and die.
We will go on living.
And if you lose your legs yet managed to
return from calf captivity on crutches,
we will convict you.
And he mentions the lending grounder Ivan
off commander of a machine gun platoon
in the Finnish war who lost
both legs and was imprisoned.
Incident lead is very naive to say
what for? In other words, what for,
why are they going to prison? At no
time have government's been moralist,
they never imprisoned people and executed
them for having done something they
imprisoned and executed them to keep them
from doing something. They imprisoned.
All those POW is of course not for
treason to the motherland because it was
absolutely clear even to a fool that only
the vlogs off men could be accused of
treason, which is a group that
we'll talk about them a little bit.
But there was a,
a general named wows off that actually
became a leader of Russian soldiers
fighting against Russia alongside
the Nazis. Hmm. So he's saying, yeah,
those guys were traders against,
but the normal pow is a normal long,
they weren't traders back to the book.
They were imprisoned to all of them.
To keep them from telling their fellow
villagers about Europe will be eye,
doesn't see the heart,
doesn't grieve for.
So just because these people had seen
what it was like, you got to go to prison,
you know too much.
You could have acquired a very harmful
spirit through living freely among
Europeans. And if you had not been
afraid to escape and continue to fight,
it meant you were a determined person
and thus doubly dangerous in the
motherland.
Thinking about that because you had the
courage to fight on and escape and get
back.
That means you're a courageous person
and you're even more of a threat because
you know how live
totally backwards.
Now, like I said, this guy flies off. Um,
he,
he was surrounded and wanted to
retreat and got told no and they,
his army was basically a lot,
most of it was wiped out.
And then he was kind of
wandering and escaped somewhat,
and they joined up with a keep captured,
joined up with some other troops that
other Russian troops that were now pissed
off, right? That they didn't,
they, you what? You weak.
You wouldn't allow us to surrender.
You wouldn't allow us to break out
your windows, allow us to leave.
So they're pissed.
It stolen.
And so then they turned and these vias
off guys ended up fighting and I'm sure
we'll do a book on these guys
at some point. But um, you know,
he became,
he became the leader,
Andre Vilas off and they fought and
they fought hard because they know,
they knew that they had no,
and they weren't going to live if
they were captured. And in fact,
um,
Solzhenitsyn says when we captured them,
we shot them in as soon as the first
intelligible Russian word came from their
mouths. The just straight up. That's
what we're doing. Oh, you speak Russian.
Cool. That means your blast
off, man. You're done.
The term of [inaudible] in our country
has the same force as the word sewage.
We feel we are during our mouths merely
by pronouncing it and therefore no one
deers dares otter. A sentence with
Velocify right in its subject.
But that is no way to write history.
Now a quarter century later when most
of them had perished and camps and those
who have survived or living out
their lives in the far north.
I would like to issue a reminder through
these pages that this was a phenomenon
totally unheard of in hauled
the whole history of the world,
that several hundred thousand young men
age 20 to 30 took up arms against their
father land as allies
of its most evil enemy.
Okay,
right. Seeing this never happened.
Hundreds of thousands of,
there was hundreds of thousands.
These flies off troops,
hundreds of thousands of them.
How do you get a hundreds of thousands
of men who are in the military like,
okay, we get a traitor,
we get five traders,
hundreds of thousands,
and he says back to the book,
perhaps there was something to ponder
here who was more to blame those youths or
the gray fatherland
one cannot explain this
trees and biologically it had
to have had a social cause
because as the old proverb said,
well fed horses don't rampage
then picture yourself a field
in which starved, neglected,
crazed horses are
rampaging back and forth.
Continuing on.
Okay.
There is a simple truth which one can
learn only through suffering in war.
Not Victories are blessed,
but defeats governments need
victories and the people need defeats.
Victory gives rise to the desire for
more victories. But after defeat,
it is freedom that men desire and
usually attain a people needs defeat.
Just as an individual needs
suffering and misfortune,
they compel the deepening of the inner
life and generate a spiritual upsurge.
That's an interesting concept.
I mean that's uh,
that's what Joe Rogan talking about.
You need to have some struggle, right?
You need to have something
to get after. Yeah. And,
and Solzhenitsyn,
sane people in a country
need that same thing.
We need that struggle.
They want that struggle.
And this is again,
this is the one we spent a little bit
of time on with Jordan and this is when,
when one of Social Knutson's,
uh,
friends in the prison
Valentyn said, oh, they
were expecting amnesty.
There was expecting to be set free.
And here we go back to,
because we dried ourselves off balance
and said to me reassuringly intimately,
well, all right, we're still young.
We're going to live a long time yet the
main thing is not to make a misstep.
Now we are going to a camp and will not
say one word to anything so they won't
plaster new terms in us. We'll work
honestly and keep our mouth shut.
And he really believed in his program,
that naive little kernel of grain of
caught between stound Stalin's millstones.
He really had his hopes set on it and
then he's talking about amnesty one wanted
to agree with them to serve out the
term Causley and then expunge from one's
head what one had lived through.
But I had begun to sense
a truth inside myself.
If in order to live it
is necessary not to live,
then what's it's off of
then what does it all for?
And of course Jordan and I got an a
bigger long discussion about playing the
game. And yeah, I mean I think we, uh,
both agreed that there's times where
you have to play the game a little bit.
Yeah.
And if you don't,
well you'll end up in a
worse position. Yeah. So
we started talking a little bit about
these kangaroo courts that went on.
And here's one of the
judges makes the statement,
we are not guided by laws but
by our revolutionary conscience.
So what does that mean?
That means we just make up whatever
the hell we want to make up.
Yeah, whatever we're going to make
up, that's what we're going to do. Um,
and in,
in
this book book part one of volume one,
he spends a lot of time talking about
these multiple cases. He goes through,
basically it's like court dramas and
he spells them out pretty good. I mean,
there's like a dialogue back and
forth between the accuser and,
and the defendants and you
know, the uproar from the
crowd and it's, it's like, uh,
it's like multiple court
dramas. One of them, um,
the Moscow church trial,
April 26th to May 7th, 1922,
there were 17 defendants including
arch priests and Laymen Accused of
disseminating the Patriarchs proclamation.
The charge was more important than
the question of surrendering or not
surrendering church valuables.
And the presiding judge says,
do you consider the state's law obligate
Tory or not? And the Patriarch says, yes.
I recognize them to the extent
that they do not contradicts,
contradicts the rules of peer piety,
Comrade Beck.
The presiding judge was astounded,
which in the last analysis
is more important to you?
The laws of the church or the point
of view of the Soviet government
getting,
this is all spelled out,
but it ends up May 7th the sentence
was pronounced of the 17 defendants,
11 war to be shot.
Okay.
Another massive show trial
against the engineers that were,
again, this goes back to the idea
that they were considered wreckers
and they had these massive show trials
and here were some of the results of the
show trials where they are,
where they sentence these guys to massive
prison terms or sentence him to death.
Thus it was attained with eight horse
traction. All the goals of the trial.
One. All the shortages in the country,
including famine, cold lack of clothing,
chaos, an obvious stupidities we're
all blamed on the engineer wreckers
to the people were terrified by the threat
of imminent intervention from abroad
and were therefore prepared
for new sacrifices.
Three leftist circles in the west
were warned of the intrigues of their
governments and for the solidarity
of the engineers was destroyed.
All the intelligentsia was given a good
scare and left divided within itself.
Hmm.
Every of these show trials.
Well,
if it wasn't for the fact that people
were being imprisoned or executed after
the show trials, hmm. It would be a lot
of them. They seem like kangaroo courts.
They seemed comical when you read them.
Next chapter called the supreme measure,
which is about capital punishment.
Capital punishment has an up
and down history in Russia
in the 20 central provinces of Russia.
In a period of 16 months from June,
1918 to October,
1919 more than 6,000 persons were shot,
which is to say more than 1000 per month.
The Revolution had hastened to rename
everything so that everything would seem
new.
Thus the death penalty was
rechristened as the supreme measure.
No longer a punishment,
but a means of social defense.
So they're executing a lot of people,
of course they're calling it the
supreme measure and they they, they,
they refer to as social defense.
Like we're just of how you
were just defending ourselves
right back to the book.
And what kind of evil doers with
these condemned men's wear did?
So many plotters and troublemakers
come from among them. For example,
we're six collective farmers who
are guilty of the following crime.
After they had finished
mowing the collective farm
along with their own hands,
they had gone back and mowed a second
time along the hummocks to get a little
hay for their own cows.
The all Russian at Central
Executive Committee refuse
to pardon all six of these
peasants and sentence.
And the sentence of
execution was carried out
even if Stalin had killed no others.
I believe he deserved to be drawn and
quartered just for the lies lives of those
six peasants.
So there you go.
You already harvested all the
grain you can and then you go out,
you do another run to get a little bit,
hey for your own cows and they kill you.
During those two years of 1937 and 1938
a half million political prisoners had
been shot throughout the Soviet Union
and 480,000 habitual fees in addition.
So we're talking execution on just
a mass scale that's two years.
1 million just rattled off
a million.
Okay.
Back to the book. And almost
always a person obediently allows
himself to be killed.
Yeah.
Why is it that the death penalty
has such a hypnotic effect?
Those pardoned recall hardly anyone in
their cell who offered any resistance.
Does hope lend strength
or does it weaken a man?
That's a good question,
isn't it?
It does hope lend strength
or does it weaken a man?
You had a talk that I witnessed
recently and you mentioned this,
something you just sorta mentioned for
the first time that I heard where you
were talking about hell week when
you said that they'd say, hey,
you know, you don't get much
sleep. Right. And they say, okay,
now we're going to give you guys a break.
You know, six hours sleep. Yeah, yeah, no,
they'd say something like,
Hey look,
your hell week has been extra hard and
we went too hard on you by accident and
the water was colder than normal.
So what we're gonna do is
we're going to give you guys,
we don't normally do this,
we're going to give you guys an eight
hour recovery period. It's so go,
go put on warm clothes. You know
you're going to go in the barracks,
you're not going to go in the tense.
You're going to go in your
barracks putting a war,
put on your dry clothes and getting
your beds and you guys are waking up at
eight hours. Yeah, but we need to do
a little training pause right now.
And then, and then they
put you in, did they do it?
And then they put you in there and you
get all dry and then they put you on your
bed and you're all my sounds.
And then 20 minutes later they come in
with machine guns and they wake you up
and say, go get this. Or
if again, and they do.
And that's one of the things that
gets a lot of people to quit. Yeah.
It's a lot of people to quit. Right. So
that's kind of the point where, yeah,
the hope can Jim Ula? Oh yeah.
Where that hope, you know like,
oh,
I can't believe in the one it's taken
away from you real quick or something like
that. Oh yeah. Well this is a great
question because think if, okay,
if you're in a situation where
you could live or die, right.
There's times where, hey, if I'm going
to die, it makes me stronger. Like, Hey,
I'm going to go out hardly
ever. Yeah, exactly right.
But also like if I can hope I can live,
then that can make you like a fucking
fight a little bit longer if I hope of
survival. Yeah. So there's hope.
Okay.
Lends strength or does it weaken Amanda
and there's different cases where it
does different things to you? Yeah.
Depends on what kind of strength to,
I feel like, yeah, I
dunno. Hope of what to do.
Like for sure of life is different.
Life and death because death,
that's the end of everything. That's
like, you know, but like, yeah,
but think about this situation you're,
this is talking about death.
Like you're going to be executed.
So let me ask you this.
So you're going to be executed.
But there's, if there's a
little bit of hope that,
oh,
maybe the sentence will get overturned
or maybe I'll get pushed down the road.
Or maybe they'll do an amnesty and
I'll get out. That's hope, right? Yeah.
So that might weaken you, right?
Because if you're like, look,
I'm getting executed and I don't care.
And you know what,
when that guard comes in here,
it's hot.
Get some of my buddies and we're
going to get after it. Oh yeah. Right.
So that's going to make you stronger.
So hope might not necessarily be
a good thing. I mean, you know,
if you ever encountered
someone that had no hope,
they can be very scary individuals because
they don't care if they live or die.
They don't got nothing to lose and
nothing to lose, nothing to lose.
You ever see a sports game
where it can go like, like a,
a team gets a good lead and then they
just start taking risks and they start
dominating, right? Yeah. I mean it can
happen where they can start getting cocky,
but like, uh, you can see a sports
game where it happens in fights.
It happens in MMA fights that I
started getting the upper hand.
It happens in Jujitsu.
I started getting the upper hand.
I take a little bit more risk,
but the risk,
as long as the risk pay off that Nelson
and you're, if you and I are rolling,
I take a little risk like I up for the
takedown. Right? I'm feeling cocky.
Go for the take down. I get the take down
right now all of a sudden your, your,
your hope those down. Right. And
mine's going up more and more. Yeah.
But if you're really tired and the rounds
almost over and you already lost and
now you're just like, well, I got no hope,
I'm just going to try for an arm lock.
You might get it. Yeah. Yeah.
And that's what I was going
to say too. It's like, man,
it's the on both sides. So it just
depends. Both really the answer is well,
because like look,
MMA analogy,
good one in my opinion to where let's
say I'm down as a football team as a
whatever, and you start throwing hail,
Mary's doing that kind of stuff. You know,
it's like you have kind of less
hope we're going to lose anyway.
Nothing to lose situation.
So it does give you strength in that way.
But at the same time, if you way
ahead, yeah, I can take more risks.
I'll put my second string guys in
there, give them some reps, whatever.
Cause if you know, if the, if the
risk does it pay off of whatever,
we're still ahead so we're, you know,
man, I don't know. Yeah. It just depends.
You know what? I think
the, the thing is here,
you got to pay attention as a human
to what the hope is doing to you.
Right. It just gives us a good lesson
learned to what is the hope doing?
Cause it happens in your life too,
right?
Like maybe or like had
a job and you're like,
well I might get that promotion
so I'm just going to stick it out.
I'm just gonna stick it out a
little bit longer and then the butt.
Whereas if you're like, hey, you're
not getting promoted, you'd be like,
all right and you don't want to do
is I'm gonna get my resume together,
I'm going to get my act together and
I put that word. If you have hope,
it makes you a little weaker. Yeah.
So you've got to pay attention to it.
But it could make you stronger
though. It'd be like, oh,
I might get the promotion so I'm going to,
I'm going to work hard.
You gotta pay attention to where hope is
doing to you. That's what you gotta do.
Hope isn't always good. It's not bad.
It was not good. You got figure out,
you got to monitor your hope. Don't
get your hopes up. You know like that.
Could you hope you had a monitor?
That whole fit their monitor your
hope. There you go. That continues on.
Here we go.
If the condemned men and every sale
had ganged up on the as they came in
and and choked them,
wouldn't this have ended executioners
sooner than the appeals to the all Russian
central executive committee when one
is already on the edge of the grave?
Why not resist,
but wasn't everything for doomed
anyway from the moment of arrest.
Yet all the arrested crawled along the
path of hope on their knees as if their
legs had been amputated.
Monitor your hope wanted it.
Oh,
he describes sort of death row.
In one of the prisons,
there were four death cells in this prison
in the same corridor as the juvenile
cells and the hospital's cells.
The death cells had two doors,
the customary wooden door with a
people and door made of iron grading.
Each door had two locks and one
jailer had the block supervisor.
Each had a key one jailer and of the
blocks supervisor each had a key to a
different one, so the doors could
only be opened by the two together.
Sell 43 was on the other side of a
wall of the interrogators office.
And at night, while the condemned
men were waiting to be executed,
their ears were tormented by the
screams of prisoners. Being tortured.
Talks about the idea of hunger strikes,
which they did some hunger
strikes along the way
from our experience in the past
and our literature of the past.
We have derived a naive faith
in the power of a hunger strike.
But the hunger strike is
purely a moral weapon.
It presupposes that the jailer has not
entirely lost his conscience or that the
jailer is afraid of public opinion.
Only in such circumstances
can it be effective.
So yeah, the, the Soviet prison, I
didn't care. Say whatever you want.
We control the press. Oh, and by the way,
you think I'm gonna feel guilty that
you're starving. No one, not a lot of, oh,
and by the way, if I do feel like I want
to make you live, guess what? They did?
Forced artificial feeding.
This method was adapted without any
question from the experience with wild
animals in captivity.
Artificial feeding has
much in common with rape.
And that's what it really is for big men
hurled themselves on one week being in
deprivate of its one interdiction.
They only need to do it once and what
happens to it next is not important.
The of rape in hears in the
violation of the victims will,
it's not going to be the way you want it,
but the bay,
but the way I want it lie down and submit,
they pry open the mouth with a flat disk,
then broadened the crack between the
jaw and insert a tube, swallow it.
And if you don't swallow it,
they shove it down farther any way and
then pour liquefied food right down the
esophagus and then they massage the
stomach to prevent the prisoner from
resorting to vomiting.
Yeah,
the sensation is one of
being morally defiled.
Okay.
And
this is,
it's the,
it's the closing of this part of the book.
We no longer know the
answer to the question.
Is the soul of a person in the new type
prison in the special purpose prison
purified or does it
parish once and for all?
If the first thing you see each and every
morning is the eyes of your cellmate
who has gone insane,
how then shall you save yourself
during the coming day?
And like I said, that's,
I'll take that as a,
as a spot to close out that
part one of this book about the Gulag,
and I think that
is a question that we
can ask ourselves all up.
Okay,
in our current
world,
but how can we save ourselves every day?
When you look around at the world
when it looks sometimes like
the world is going insane,
when people are going crazy,
you have to kind of work
to save yourself everyday.
You have to pull yourself back into
sanity in back onto the path and not allow
yourself to become a prisoner
of your own personal gulag.
And these gulags,
these Soviet gulags,
if you want to build your own
personal gulag in your life,
you do it the same way
that the Soviets did it.
You do it with lies,
lies on top of lies.
When the Soviets lied on top of lies
to build these gulags and in your life,
if you lie to yourself,
if you allow that to happen and
you put lies on top of lies,
you will build yourself
your own personal gulag.
Yeah.
So
don't allow it.
Don't lie to yourself.
Okay.
And instead you keep
yourself out of that prison.
We keep yourself free by telling yourself
the truth.
And I think that's all I've got
for tonight.
And I know Echo,
you've got some the ways that we can kind
of help keep ourselves free by staying
on the path. Sure. On top of telling
the truth on top of telling the truth,
which is kind of the key,
right? The key element.
It's a key element for sure. I was still
kind of tripping on the hope thing,
you know, if that gives you
strength or, or takes it from you.
Right. That's how you put it or that's how
he put it. Right. It takes it from you.
I was, I was talking to Dakota. Yeah.
The other night and we were
talking about after the big event,
we know where he lost
his team and all that.
And we just talked a little
bit more detail about the,
if you remember in the book,
a few days later,
he goes on another operation that's just
as crazy or maybe not just as crazy,
but it's like it's really bad.
Yeah.
And he was doing some definitely some,
some crazy things and putting,
what's the military term that we say he
was going above and beyond the call of
duty and putting himself at great risk.
And I said to him, you know, we were,
we were kind of like lab, you know,
Dakota is so good to go and so awesome.
And we were just like laughing.
And I was like, well, you didn't see, I
mean, at that point I'm like, you just,
you know, you lost your whole team. I
go, you didn't care if you lived or died.
He goes, naughty. Not at all. Yeah. And
so when that situation that he had no
hope at that moment in time. Right.
And guess what he did? Whatever
he had to do. He's like, Oh,
I've got to go save the,
I'm going to go run across open field
where there's machine gun fire coming.
Cool. I'll go, oh wait new dude again.
I'll go again. Oh I need to do it again.
I'll go again. Yeah.
Cause he didn't have hope.
And in fact that he didn't have hope.
Gave him strength at that moment. Yeah.
You know, at that moment. But if you
talk to them now it's for versed.
He's got his kids, got his little
daughters, you know what I mean?
He's got like hope for the future.
Yeah.
And that's what makes me strong
right now until keeps him strong.
What's the formula? Right. And I mean
it's, the formula is monitor your home.
That's the formula. And it
depends on who you are, right.
Because they consider yourself,
let's say all hope is lost, you know,
I gotta you know, go across, do all
these crazy things above and beyond.
I could be, if I have a different
attitude, I could be like, why?
Like why fight it kind of thing.
That death, impending doom, you know,
just kind of take its course
kind of thing. Right. I mean,
could complete disregard for
his own safety. That's the,
that's the phrase I was
looking for. Complete disregard
for his own safety. Yeah.
But that's like a specific like
approach, you know, that's it.
Like a different attitude. You know,
like some people they'll be like, oh,
I'm gonna, you know, like I'm, I'm doomed
anyway. So why fight it? And then right,
like I'm doing, so just start swinging
for the fence and check this out.
You could also be like,
I hope I can make it out of here.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
just gonna hide right here.
And you didn't do anything that's
the same. This like the reverse.
It's the reverse. So
it's like, and then if,
if you're in a bad situation and you're
like, well, I hope I can make it.
I've got hope that I can
live through this situation,
so I'm just going to get down. I'm just
gonna hide. Get behind this little,
you know, rock outcropping and hope this
goes away. Right. Hope they don't see me.
Hope. Hope. Hope, hope. Yeah, and
that's the example of the home.
Guess what happens when you do that?
The enemy maneuvers on you and you'd
get killed. Whereas if you go like,
you know what, I'm going out, I
have no hope I'm going to attack.
But by the way,
the enemy who's hoping they can take
you and hoping that you're going to stay
there when you, when you do
something that they didn't hope for,
that's going to smack him in the face.
But like if,
but then on the reverse side of that,
right,
let's say you have a different attitude
even though you have hope, right?
If all is lost,
do you think,
but I have this little shred of hope so
I'm just going to go throw a hail Mary
that's hope really.
Rather than just like cowering in
the corner and dying or whatever.
But you wouldn't be throwing a hail
Mary unless that was the only way.
Like that was your only hope. Shred of
hope was the only, I'm saying like if you,
that's what I'm saying. Like, if you
have two different approaches, you know,
monitor your hope at the end of the day,
that's going to monitor your home on,
got to make sure that what?
Cause
there's, you gotta be careful too because
sometimes you know, if you have no hope,
right? If you out well, I have no hope so
I'm just gonna cause you could do that,
right? Let's say you're in a bad
situation, a combat situation. Hey,
I got no hope so I'm just
going to lay here and like,
I guess this is what you were
saying. Oh yeah, I got no hope.
So I'm just gonna lay here instead of,
hey,
I got no hope so I'm just going to go out
in a blaze of glory. Let's get science.
Yeah, go down swinging approach.
So if you monitor it, you go,
wait a second. I have no hope. Okay.
I'm going to at least go out hard.
I'm going to go get some at a minimum,
right?
I'm going to take some people with me,
bad guys.
We'll save some of my good
guys if I can do that. Yeah,
that's good. As opposed to, hey,
there's no hope, we're doomed.
Monitor your hope.
Remember that? Remember
Shawshank redemption? Yes.
I have seen that movie where he was
like, Hey, the guy read Morgan Freeman.
He's insane. Hey, don't be
careful with that whole thing.
It will drive you insane.
Or something like that.
Like if you hope you'll get out or
you hope you're going to get part into
whatever his situation
was. So it's like, yeah,
if you hope you'll get pardoned
and you hold onto that hope,
but you get let down, it will
create, it will drive you insane.
And if you don't have hope and not do what
he's implying, if you don't have hope,
you just said basically accept your
imprisonment so you can focus on our
concentrate unliving prison life.
You know the way it needs to be lived,
so to speak. Do the best
you can there. Yeah.
Like don't have these hopes so the
outside cause it'll make you crazy.
That could be decent advice in a situation
like that. Yeah. One of those deals.
Monitor your hope
is what he was saying.
That's what he was saying.
It's saying monitor your hope
because right. If you have
no hope, you can be like,
well, I'm just gonna just gonna kill
myself. Yeah, exactly. Right. Yeah,
and I know you've got a monitor
it in the prison. All right.
And you got to make sure that you're not
putting yourself in a personal prison.
Yeah. Which I, which that to me,
this idea,
if you think about the bad
situations in your life,
most of them are predicated on you
lying to yourself about something.
Yeah. Yeah. Your everyday
ones for sure. Yeah.
Right. Yeah. It's weird. Every time
you, like you say something like that,
how I always try to think of something
rebuttal. You know? It's weird.
I feel myself doing that, but yeah,
no, you're right. Yeah. I think so
that you just tell these little
lies lies on top of lies and,
and what's what I think what
happens with lies on top of lies is
they become easier and easier to believe.
Oh yeah.
Like once you believe one of your
own lives, then you believe three,
then you believe 10 then
you believe a hundred. Yeah.
You know what the feeling is, the
feeling is you lie to yourself, right?
And or you could, a lot of times
lying to yourself isn't like, hey,
I'm tall. When you're not
taught, it's not that. It's like,
it's more of a not admitting certain
things. That's more what it is. You know?
Like when you saw how you
can say, he say, look,
take a good hard look at yourself
in the mirror. Right end.
And don't lie to yourself.
Right.
So it's usually when you lie to
yourself in the mirror, it's like, oh,
I won't admit that I won't,
I won't admit that to myself that I
need this or I should get rid of this or
whatever. That's how the light comes.
You know? It's a lie by omission.
I think this look, then the more
you do it, yeah. But then you,
and then you lived to see another
day. Whoa. It's a miracle.
So it must kind of be true.
It must not be that big of a deal.
My whatever,
you know,
like donuts that I eat every
morning for breakfast must not be,
I'm still here for those arise.
So it is so in,
no one's bringing it up.
No one's bringing it up to me kind of
thing. So it's like it's not really,
it's not like pulling at me that much.
So it gets easier and easier to kind of,
it's almost like sweeping it under
the rug kind of thing. You know?
Meanwhile that's festering and festering.
Oh,
she'd go to the doctor cholesterol so
high or whatever. See what I'm saying?
That's how it'll jam. Ya'll don't lie
to yourself, you know, what else is it?
Prison being on bottom,
stuck in your side,
control in Jujitsu to prison.
So, and here's the weird thing,
when you,
when he said that I,
I did think of this where if I have,
and it's,
I don't even know if I'd call it hope.
Like if I want to be out,
like if I want to escape,
not that I want to do the escape room
or take escape type actions is just I
don't want to be there all like it.
Way less like a won't,
I won't be able to deal with
it as much as if I say, okay,
I'm here. It's like accepting that
I'm an insight control, you know,
and I have to take action here. My
hope is here, not outside there.
See what I'm saying? You have to
accept the situation that you're in.
You can't lie to yourself.
Lie Little prison. Anyway.
I think that's what Morgan Freeman
was talking about by the way.
Nonetheless we can site control.
That's Jujitsu. Speaking of Jujitsu,
you're going to need a geek if you're
an in doing Jujitsu. Indeed. Yeah.
We're on the path. We're talking
about the path right now. Right.
Support yourself in this way by saying
in the path to starting. Do you too.
If you haven't already.
A lot of people starting to get to a
lot more people started jujitsu getting
popular, very popular and for
good reason too. I mean shoot,
so when you get a g and a rash
guard get origin g no question.
Oh, you don't want to agree with me. I
agree with her. That's what I thought.
Anyway. Origin, main.com origin main.com.
It's the,
I guess the look that I was giving you
is sort of the fact that we just glossing
over the fact that these
geezer made 100% in America.
Yeah, yeah. Maybe I should talk
about the last time you did,
you talked about the looms and all
that stuff today you're just, Hey,
the best ski so which
I guess that's cool. Yeah, they
are. They are all is true for sure.
100% yeah and, and you know what,
I'm a, I was just about to say this,
but I remembered that I do talk about
this all the time on air and off air.
That it is cool. It kind of like how
Pete guys, how they brought back like
the actual making of the g for example.
Like that's a thing now it's like cool.
Now no one cared about how your g was
stitched him and like no one cared about
that stuff.
Even if they knew the pearl competitions
last time I was there was I got like
legit
explanation of things from Pete
because Pete and I were just like,
it's 10 o'clock at night.
We've been working for eight days
straight and we're just in there getting,
and I'm asking him pointed questions
about stuff about how this thing gets,
you know what I mean? Cause I
want to understand it. Yeah.
There's a lot of those guys that
had to learn a lot of stuff.
You can't even, it's, I think
it's been five years, six years,
the amount of information that had
to be learned from nut, from no,
from nothing. From nothing. No. From
trial and error. It's a funny ass Pete.
That code and stuff like you
can't exhaust Pete who yeah,
you see the twinkle in his eye. He wants
to explain it. He's all halls concerned.
Those boring you guys with it. Oh Man.
Stay off to that for sure. But yeah,
origin g a hundred percent origin rask
guard 100% supplements too, by the way.
And I wasn't not,
I wouldn't call myself anti supplement.
And I'm going to say that, but I wasn't
into supplements that much before.
Now I am.
Because you know when you come
across the one that actually works,
that's the thing. You know,
plenty of people, there are
plenty supplements. It's,
they sorta rely, maybe
not 100%, maybe 100%,
but they rely on the placebo effect.
So when you have supplements
like these that actually work,
you becoming supplement person.
So if you want them got joint
warfare for your joints,
obviously Krill oil for your life,
like leading your joints,
joints in your just overall health
discipline for when you got to get that
workout and there's discipline drink
and there's discipline. Go pills go,
go. And then it was more, you hit
some kind of mock scenario going on.
Technically it was warrior kitten
monk's last night we go to,
okay, there's this light show,
Christmas lights Shill, right.
Um, you know, the, you know,
certain neighborhoods they'll have,
I guess this one is like super
famous, like shoot tracers. No,
no,
it's called the,
I think Balardo I think it's called
Balardo light show. It's like, you know,
Christmas lights, this house, they do it
for thing. It has a whole show and people,
you know, so we go and you know, my
wife, she likes the Christmas spirit.
Get all cozy, right? It's kind of
colder now, California. Cool. Dig It.
No offense, no offense.
Iowa, no friends. Main, yeah,
no offense. But California cold,
we'll say you can see your breath.
You're talking 40 49 degrees
anyway,
so like in,
in like Michigan or Minnesota.
It's 54 below in Montana
it's 54 below zero.
So anyways, continue a little
bit different. Sure. But still,
but for the Charles Families Warrior
Little Chili or according to my wife at
warranted, maybe a hot chocolate scenario.
So look, this is what we're going to do,
driver, it's kind of close
to miles who drive around.
We're gonna look at all the nice lights.
We'll drink our hot chocolate
and the car would bring the kids.
It'd be fun if we can get out. So
everyone's busted out their hot chocolate.
Of course. What, what do you think my
hot chocolate was? Yeah. Oh, I know what.
That's the warrior kid milk hot chocolate.
I even put some whipped cream on it.
Oh yeah.
It was nice actually.
It was surprisingly nice surprise.
I was,
this is why usually I drink the regular
moke under different circumstances.
It's like boom, milkshake, but home, you
know. But you get the kid, consider this.
Consider where I was. I had
two, two kids and one wife,
all with regular hot chocolate. May or
may not have had marshmallows in it.
Either way. Regular hot
chocolate and me I'm with, okay,
I'm going to stick with the protein
where your kids, so you didn't get,
your kids didn't have native
homie. That's, that's messed up.
Here's the thing that to your kids,
yeah, I was younger, I was Gunna,
but we're kinda in a hurry and I made
the game timeline. It was already made.
I'm not going to be like, hey, there's no
either way. Actually that's a good point.
Next time. 100% nonetheless, I
heat it up. It tastes the same.
Literally tastes. This is freaking
awesome. Same as regular hot chocolate.
So anyways, that's warrior kid
mall. You've got strawberry.
And chocolate and then for, I had a guy
at the gym the other day and he was,
he's like, oh, I'm drinking
some milk right now. And I
was like, oh cool. I was like,
anybody hadn't know,
like one of those metal water bottle,
like a water bottle looking thing.
And I go, what did you mix it with?
And he's like, water. And I go, Bro, you
got to, you got to get milk in there.
And he goes, really? And I go, yeah,
I go almond milk, coconut milk,
one of the kinds of milks are
their almond milk. I said,
just get some acid or whole milk,
just milk or skim milk, whatever.
I saw him yesterday. He
said, Bro, you're kidding.
And I'm like, he was, no, I'm drinking it
all the time. And I know. Yeah, I know.
And he was actually telling me he liked
it just as is with water, which I can't,
I can't, I'm not going to make that
claim because I don't believe it. Right.
I'm not saying like, Hey,
if you drink with water,
it's going to be great or you drink
with waters. Okay. It's like, like I,
like I said before, drink with
water. It's like a ham sandwich.
If you drink it with milk, it's like
prime rib. Yeah, it's like a Ribeye.
Sure. I didn't know what he
was doing. I didn't know.
I didn't know his exact scenario
and I wasn't even there.
I don't even know what
you're talking to him.
He's used to like drinking protein
drink shakes in the shaker,
you know off the live mix them want
just throw it in with water or whatever.
That's what he's forcing
it down. Yeah. Yeah.
That's what he's used to open it with it.
Open your mouth,
the ses gamma tube down your
esophagus to get your protein.
You don't need to do that with milk.
There's no forced feeding.
But that's what I'm saying. So now
he mixed it. Same deal. Same routine,
but now we've got the mock tastes better.
Cool. Puts it in. Oh yeah, you're right.
Where's Jocko? Let me find them. You
know, kind of thing. And you're like, Bro,
you're not even on the, you are
in the milk train fully. But man,
you could be up here in first class.
See what I'm saying?
Rather than the in the caboose. Cool, man.
Either way,
just get on it and get all this stuff
or didn't mean.com also web store.
We have a store,
Jocko,
store.com this is where you can get
more rash guards for Jujitsu approved.
By the way, 100% approved.
This is more, you know,
representing the path directly
in those rash guards. Anyway,
some good rash guards on their shirts,
shirts and hats, beanies, hoodies,
legit hoodies and yeah,
go to [inaudible] dot com
you'll also Jocko white tea,
which yes, he's at the,
funny enough my wife is,
she's on this there. Jocko white tea
train. This is not, but if there was,
she would be the engineer.
She'll even say I'm about to get after it.
Right before she did.
I guess this is why you can't create
viral marketing, right? You can't be like,
hey, let's come up with a viral
thing for Jocko white tea. Hey,
get on the Jocko white tea train.
Like that doesn't work, I guess.
Whereas most chain hundred percent
trains Shoulda just formulated itself.
That's what I mean. Yeah, you're right.
It preexisted in some universe
and then when it arrived here,
it was like Choo Choo,
get on
a chuck anyway. Jocko white tea. Yes.
Deadlift 8,000 pounds,
whatever.
I've been dead lifting 8,000
pounds for a long time already.
So that is less exciting then
it's going to be for the,
you know the people who just
start just saying, but yeah, sure.
Somebody asking you could dead lift 1600
pounds if he, if you drink two cans,
now you just want to say this,
but uh, no, it doesn't work.
That doesn't work that way. Yeah, no,
exactly right. Exactly right. Nonetheless,
in Cannes and in, what
do you call it? Dry Tea.
Prefer the cans personally, but the
dry, it tastes good too. For sure.
Available on Amazon and at
the chocolate store, right?
Yes sir. Dot Com. Yeah. Cool.
Everywhere. Just go on line Jocko.
White tea. Boom. Right in your mailbox.
Also subscribe to the podcast.
If you haven't already on Google and
wherever play whenever you get Pi.
Hey,
check out the warrior kid podcast.
If you've got kids or even
if you don't have kids,
if you know kids get in
the warrior kid podcast,
I have a couple more episodes coming out
this week of the warrior kid podcasts
so you can get some of that.
Also you can get that warrior kids soap
from Irish oaks ranch made by an actual
warrior kid named Aiden who
makes it with goat milk. Yeah.
So if you want to get some soap
so that you can follow his motto,
which is stay clean and then youtube,
subscribe to youtube if you want to see
what Echo Charles looks like. It's true.
If you want to see what
a guest looks like,
if you want to see the
look on [inaudible] face,
when I say something that he doesn't
agree with or if you want to see the look
on my face when he says something,
uh, that was one of the funniest
outtakes was you talking and then you,
but you were just showing my face just
like so bored and annoyed and yes,
there is a few of those.
There's one where I was talking about
justifying like not doing squats or
whatever and you're just like this.
I thought the funny thing was
already you're talking about,
so I'm going to an alien thing and I just
showed my face and I'm just looking at
me like, please get the hint that
my face right now means stop,
but you are actually really nice
about that. I'm are generally nice,
pretty nice person.
Well,
sometimes you take advantage of that
with stories that impinge on my whole
situation anyway,
psychological warfare,
which that's what that is by the way,
when you're just looking at me,
nothing like that.
Just looking like it's psychological.
It's psychological communication.
Anyway,
the real psychological warfare is an
album with tracks of Jocko on each track
telling you how to overcome
your moments of weakness.
That may may creep in t your whole
scenario in life when you're on the path,
you can get that on iTunes, Google
play, MP, three platforms or whatever.
You know what I said we were going to
get psychological warfare to out by
Christmas, not going to
happen. Little delay.
If you still have some requests of a,
of an area of weakness and you want us
to make a psychological warfare tracks
and you can crush and destroy that
weakness, then just let us know the uh,
you know, the usual means yes. Yeah.
Online. Cool. Yeah. All your excuses are
lies by the way. That's the working title.
Also very up your work though.
I was going to do a video today.
We'll work up video of
yourself. Yup. Cool.
And I was going to do a kettle
bell typical kettlebells
scenario and I was just
going to start doing curls with it,
but,
but I decided against it because
it's kind of disrespectful to the,
got a good idea.
You should do a workout video where you
just have a barbell Kettlebell Dumbbell,
uh, uh, a sandbag and everything.
You just don't girls
essentially the idea,
but it was kind of disrespectful.
Anyway, my point there being,
what it reminded me of
of it is that the crow,
it was going to be like really
good like produced video.
Not necessarily with a good camera,
nothing like that, but just like,
I'm just going to frame
it good and it was good.
It was going to be using the Onnit,
kettle bell, the cyclops, whatever.
Nonetheless decided against it because
it's going to be kind of disrespectful
because that's not what
kettle bells for obviously,
but if you do get kettlebells, even if
it's funny, it's still disrespectful.
I have to what it felt like at the
time, but no, you're probably right.
I the time I was like, yeah,
it'd be all right. Yes. Anyway,
my point is even those little bit
beside the point, it reminded me of it.
The point is,
my new point is when you want to vary
up your workout curls or otherwise,
some people, they don't even do
curls. I used to do curls. You see,
do curls to don't act like you
know. No, I do. I do. Go, boom.
Get your stuff from on [inaudible]
dot com slash Jocko by the way,
kettle bells rings.
These are things that not only do I do
pretty much every workout pretty much,
but this is, these are ones that I
strongly recommend to incorporate rings.
And this last stuff you can do on rings
by the way, the pushups pull ups and uh,
the planks or whatever,
those big ups dips. Yeah.
I don't do them as much, but the
planks for sure. You don't do dips?
Not on the rings. No. Why?
I Dunno. I just don't. Okay,
let's do them on the bar nonetheless.
Good job.
These are Dang Bro.
That was a lot of heat right there for,
for no dips on the rings anyway. Get
them out on it. Good stuff on there.
Very up to workout.
Incorporate new things in the workout.
Yeah man,
it's good.
Mikey and the dragons is out.
It is in stock fully.
I'm sorry that it took a little eight.
Everyone should have gotten it
by or should get it by Christmas.
If you ordered it reasonably before
Christmas, you should have it because we,
we made it, we did it. Everyone that
ordered it, we got an Amazon fulfilled,
so appreciate everyone that ordered it.
It is now fully in stock.
We should not run out again family.
If you have Amazon prime,
that's like two days, right?
Yeah. I Dunno. I Dunno. Yeah.
I Dunno when they're cut off time is
for Amazon to get it shipped in time.
But yeah.
Um,
those are in the distribution centers
around the country with Amazon prime right
now. So if you haven't gotten Mikey in
the dragons for every kid that you know,
then you can get it done right now.
We got a lot of copies ready to roll.
So get it for your kids, get it for your
neighbor's kids, get it for your library,
whatever.
You can also get the way of the warrior
kid books way the warrior kid and Mark's
mission. If you want your kids or kids,
you know, to actually have a good life,
this is a great way to start them off
actually having a good life. Yes. Another,
this is a holiday gift.
If there ever one
was one discipline equals freedom.
Feel better.
I need to post that video actually a
post that video repost. Oh yeah, yeah,
yeah. Get that video posted. But yeah,
because that's a good gift to give to
anyone that needs to be on the pros in the
morning. If you want to get the audio
version of that, it's not on audible,
it's on iTunes, Amazon music,
Google play, et cetera.
Extreme ownership of course,
dichotomy of leadership,
possibly better than extreme ownership.
I've gotten like four last four people
I talk to. I was like, ah, possibly.
And they're like, no, it's
definitely better. And that's
kind of weird, right? Yes.
Is that, yeah, well, [inaudible]
go flare up. You know what I mean?
Maybe, but I don't really get that
from what you just said right now I,
here's my hypothesis that people who were,
who were saying that dichotomy,
leadership is better
than extreme ownership,
better than extreme ownership or people
who read extreme ownership and then
we're like, yeah, you know, hell
yeah, I'm going to extreme ownership.
And then they go in and they're
like, okay. It's like, you know,
I made the analogy of the
guy on major league, right?
The picture. He had all this power,
but he didn't have any control.
Dichotomy of leadership comes in,
gives them that control that
they wish that they had. Yeah.
They didn't even know they didn't have it.
They didn't know they didn't have it.
They thought the extra
mile to a mile thing.
A seal buddy of mine came over to my
house the other day and he brought 20
copies of extreme ownership.
His wife wanted to give his,
giving them to her team in
the company and he goes,
yeah, you know, I'm giving, you know,
my wife really wants to give him,
and she's read it. She
loves it. And then he goes,
but she's kind of a bull in a China
shop. Yes. And I was like, okay,
cool. So I guess what
I did, I was like, Hey,
let me give a little something
for your wife's Christmas present,
giving her a little Christmas present.
Yep.
We have a little something called
dichotomy of leadership because that's the
situation you're talking about.
Oh, you know what though,
it's the perfect situation. Like you
think, oh, I'm going to go take ownership.
And it's like, well, or even like
everyone's going to read this book, it's,
I'm dichotomy of leadership.
Let's make sure we're balanced.
Yeah. Actually though,
you know what,
you know what I just thought of right now?
I gotta I gotta take it back.
Maybe, maybe not. Maybe I'm right.
Maybe I'm not with that whole analogy.
But you know what though?
What's more important?
Power or bow or, or,
or what do you call accuracy or whatever.
Right? Cause it's Kinda the same thing.
Extreme ownership is like, oh, here's what
you do. Full speed. This is what you do.
And then the dichotomy is kind of the
control element. What's more important?
Control or speed. See what I'm saying?
Controller. [inaudible] controller.
They're both important. I think so too.
Yeah. At the end of the day, that's,
I think that's the scenario though.
You won't have,
you won't have anything to balance if
you don't understand the fundamental
principles of combat leadership.
Right?
So you got to have the balance
and Justin's gotta be, yeah.
So get those books. Good
Christmas presents. Or
I'm the worst gift giver. Eh, you're not
very good for you. Let me take that back.
If I get you a gift, which is
not likely. Yeah, it'll be great,
but it's a slim chance.
You're getting one. Well,
how many gifts have you gotten
from me to what I give you?
Well one actually a technical
I don't think was from you.
You gave me a copy of the discipline
equals freedom field manual signed or like
on your own. Like it wasn't like,
Hey, give me, you are like, hey,
you know this is for you. Go.
That was cool. What else? Nice.
That's cool. Cause I've written six
books. I'm giving you one. There you go.
You're batting or about average. Only
20% of the time. My daughter one. That's,
you're exactly right. Not me with
different, no, you gave me something.
I think it was like a shirt or something.
Then I found out like later that
day that it wasn't from you.
You're just a message that was given to
you. One gift. Thanks for that by the way.
Check. Ah, also we've
got an echelon front.
That's my leadership consultancy and
what we do is go into companies and uh,
solve problems through leadership.
Go to echelon,
front.com if you want to
work with me and my team,
which is Leif Babin, JP Denelle,
Dave Burke, Flynn Cochran,
Mike's Raleigh and Mike [inaudible].
Also,
we got the monster coming up.
It is live for registration right now.
Chicago,
Denver and Sydney Australia.
Go to extreme ownership.com right now if
you want to come, they've all sold out.
This one is going to actually
we opened registration.
It's already like these are going to sell
a lot faster for whatever reason. Yeah.
Interesting. How your we're
going to Australia. Yeah.
Cause a lot of people were saying,
you know, if for some reason I didn't,
I went to Brisbane, Australia and
I did a book signing in Brisbane,
Australia and I announced it on like
a Wednesday or a Thursday and the book
signing was on Friday and I showed up
and there was hundreds and hundreds of
people there. Um, yeah,
I was super stoked about that and it
showed that there was a lot of people that
we're supporting and of course
we've got e f Overwatch,
which is us connecting proven leaders
from Spec ops and combat aviation
communities with companies in the civilian
sector that need experienced leaders
to step up and lead inside
their organizations to go
to eff Overwatch and fill
out the information there either as
a talent seeker or a career seeker.
We're waiting to link you guys
up. You know, speaking of events,
we are doing a live event.
We are doing a live event,
New York City January 9th
details to be announced.
But if you want to come,
it's in a theater and we're going to
record a podcast live in the theater and
then we're going to do
Q and a live I think.
Or maybe I'll assemble questions from the
group. Yeah, like the old
school, old school, half,
half, multiple, half and half.
That's what we're going to do. Something
like that. Anyways, calendar yourself,
uh,
January 9th New York City.
If you're in that area or do you want
to come hang out? Come and get some.
We will see you there and if you
want to link up with us virtually,
we are pretty readily
available on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram and on Facebook.
Kibo hop echo is that Echo Charles and
I am at Jocko Willink and thanks to all
the military personnel out there that are
providing us with this way of life and
you can see how bad life can get
when you read a book like
the Gulag Archipelago. Also,
thanks to police and law enforcement,
firefighters, paramedics,
EMT is correctional officer's border
patrol and all first responders have for
protecting this way of life
that we have here at home.
And to everyone else out there,
just remember that this nightmare of the
gulags started when people can't quiet
on a large scale
and on a small scale.
Don't let that happen on a large
scale and don't let it happen to you.
Okay?
Resist that whole opening
chapter about not resisting.
Don't let that happen.
Resist, resist the weakness,
resist the lies,
resist the things in your life that
will turn you into a prisoner and into a
slave.
And you'd do that by
going out there every day
and getting after it.
Okay.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.